he should be on a lobster told stay
players still haven't resigned Patrick
there's a possible names are gas when
they come through Denver they were also
close to a nude beach and that was not
good
come inside Caruso right there I think
the center position is in pretty good
yeah in Denver part three Chumbley
defense Hart says finally finally it's
gonna go in and was altered by bionics
stolen by Caruso underlay the defender
Travis red sapphire doesn't get great
smile warmth keeping people together
being a great teammate you don't think
of anyone before you believe in magic
Johnson bridges
Carrie's been again here Kobe Bryant had
his Achilles blowout at the end of the
regular season Dwight Howard was a Laker
as McGee is fouled on the Throwdown they
brought in Steve Nash that didn't work
out because of injury how about it a
pick-and-roll caruso finding a diving
JaVale McGee takes the contact that was
the first offensive rebound for the
Lakers and Caruso gets the jump shot he
has seven points off the bench
[Applause]
Caruso to the basket and he gets the
layup and now Millsap still behind it's
a five on four Caruso fakes the pass
- OH
unplayed and right through his soul gets
another stop Caruso to fake pass
beautiful layin Laika's down to Denver
record is held by fat libro at 16 back
in 1987 touch pass by Caruso to Williams
and the rookie from Gonzaga finishes
back to a four point it's easy work I'm
playing with greatness defend to work
hard and be ready to take and make big
shots because teams it's going to be
easy for me all I gotta do is the
one-two step they know in an eight
minute spurt he can win them a playoff
game home or road you know they get it's
been such an interesting season
Williams this continues to add to his
career night 18 points nine rebounds
James in the attack exam light crowd so
far here tonight
Caruso stop it papa three nothing but
net for the great Caruso on the road
Caruso bouncing a good one to apply with
the left hand
nice assist by alex cuenca that's what's
so good about the bounce man trying to
look at that bounce nationally nice play
by the rim and you got fouls or for ten
points yeah and the total distance I
need on these total shots is one foot
screen gotta get a pack finger saw
through so just check back on the
receiving end
[Music]
joining Detroit kcp answers with another
there's the Lakers first three of the
night for 21 straight to start the
quarter against the Caruso boys shielded
it well counted at the foul he'll get an
and-one taken away from opportunity is
shields it keeps the ball away from him
you see that left here about the check
back in this offense is operating losses
it know what the play but himself if he
operated these lost patience curry some
thought about running it now he's across
the time no how about a look away New
York Caruso lets it go Jonathan Williams
go to the free-throw line see if he can
complete with this free throw will South
Bay Laker connection all free and then
you're off to the races
Caruso with the steal and the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that department about the other half
we're not score shows everywhere you
enjoyed it that difference maker when he
first signed on with the Lakers early on
as a year Alex came back down to earth a
little bit in the last game how about
that first shot
the games he's been on the floor
conversation jam that's three threes
they have 12 is a tune around underneath
but you get spliced while it stays in
Jerusalem
[Applause]
yet another four point advantages Caruso
finds LeBron for an easy flush for his
twentieth point to go along with 12
assists wily veteran he knows it Rajon
he's got a jumper if he wants us to
block controlled an ad I buy Caruso and
the assist to Rondo on the back game
layup welcome to shot and the key stat
and other revives and alters can be
better than blocks also
that was a beautiful bounce pass
sparkling bounce pass to Caruso who
throws it up and throws it in the Lakers
lead is six father he okay my fake came
back off of picking he's well with
Duncan ball oh the big guy he's blocking
shot you too nervous it'll compete on
that in and I just don't think the
priority organization and team to get to
where the right now if two guys that
have been just unreal montrezl Harrell
so thought the Jazz like what do they
care if he gets it or not just let him
score you won the game by 33 at Caruso
knocks down a three point can they get a
quality look Russo oh there's a quality
mate that's for sugar Caruso the
Pleasant they review it but a 3.0 for
Caruso first quarter complete here at
Salt Lake City jazz lead is seven and he
is I think he's in the top ten irritant
secrets under presenta the skin of the
opponents or how did that go in Wow
they've led the entire way largest lead
20 right now 16 as we open the floor
it's all what a nice pass Caruso throws
it down there in the timeout and as they
continue Autism Awareness ham
Caruso finds Williams Williams able to
knock it down
ankles ball away now a career-high 12
assists Williams flips it up and in
Caruso horses doing some things Mike
even the crowd reacted to that pass how
pretty it was Hey look at this that is
nicely done
LaRussa this is only his 18th game in
the NBA tonight he's had five different
guys throw him alive tonight meanwhile
Caruso's wrote some beautiful passes
that's his fourth assist the Magee
throws it down was so fun hearing him
talk and it's just the citizen he's had
such a great time with his Caruso
another nice shot from Caruso 13 points
and 4 assists in 20 or 25 games but he's
played in all 13 games in March he's
back
right down the middle downhill and a
slam a spectacular view to bounce past a
good finish to defenders there but
LeBron says got a half three or four
there well Lance and LeBron a
scintillating passing this split
Williams was a foul underneath by the
way Koosman kcp eight out of 13 for 21
points not McCain right now and Caruso
goes all the way to the rim a partner
found Williams who could not collect it
back you got beautiful a bike you say
Alex in a stutter step
Alex download Brack it's gonna be taken
offense simply by Caruso so they reset
at the port team Caruso over Julius
Randle Alex Caruso has double digits
here the Florida is second from long
range Julius Randle gave you too much
space to actually run plays Bosnia
elegance but he gets away as he found
the role from Caruso Hill on the other
end while by himself gets filed and he's
got another Lakers 7:21 defense offense
is human he's playing defense easy steal
for his last dunk as he he gives it to
Caruso into the attachment 47 Rousseau
tough shot no problem for him tonight he
challenges team they keep going out
right in rhythm all JaVale McGee this
could score now there's some pressure on
the funded you see ya
turns the corner Steven Adams rotates
slowly and swipes in the roof Oh Fitz
yes I have hops oh look at that focus in
add six points nine rebounds and nine
assists with a couple of blocks Tuesday
against burnouts
caldwell-pope undrafted employing a Duke
and the G Wigan is what is left inside
was Tom Cruise those are the nicest
citizen team in the West magic number
for Golden State is three Rondo three
[Applause]
Cousins is Caruso came off the weak side
and puts in the gym he is one of seven
that's Patek just a moment he gave
everybody a jolt we'll take a break then
take you to the American Express
halftime report radio here with John
Ireland doing radio broadcast for La
Russa leaves and tracks no run Clippers
this is a separation I'm talking about
let's see if they can keep it going
Caruso
al Mulaney go
working drive and get the shop a lot
muscala with the rejection
mccuddin the drive in his door in the
jam but Jonathan William there's no way
the Lakers aren't going to play hard you
have to match that let's run away
go blue so same group out there for the
Clippers picked up the intensity on the
defensive end
the new vive Wollaston got the foul 5
risotto the Texas AMM
he had a career-high 23 in a recent
grant
caldwell-pope I ran with him at least to
finish that play I need the dribble
Caruso Williams to go on the shot clock
come the Lakers again let's Carla
Rondo steps back long - they get the
rebound charisma 3
[Applause]
corrosives been an all-star
miscommunication by the Clipper so he
has 30 if this kid crowded stays with it
that's number one on the laws of
category there's another dunk this time
the alley-oop
and the finish by McGee under minute to
play here in the first quarter Allen's
in charge Alex Avila will see
caldwell-pope once again for the Lakers
in a moment Caruso all the way scores
boy he died need much room at all does
it Rita 67% in this game so they've
dumped it over 70% of people who put
gone since simple back Oh Caruso all is
falling down said did you just hear and
we bolted through the double doors into
the impromptu press conference Caruso
with the hook shot in the lane
[Music]
not been him it's Vince dancer but
Jonathan Williams has come off the bench
to aid the Lakers now to get back KCT
[Applause]
the way back they play hard they don't
give up who plays Colusa 43 I definitely
the back not when you consider it sucks
yes what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content